but actually many theoretical physicists
are more inclined to think that our
universe is made up not of little
billiad ball particles but of universe
wide Fields this fits better for example
with Quantum field Theory and the
particles are really just local
excitations in those fields so if you
combine this view with pans
sism then we get the view that the
fundamental forms of consciousness
underly these Universe wide
fields and that the most basic mind
is the bearer of those fields namely the
universe itself so this is what we call
Cosmos psychism The View that the
universe as a conscious entity is the
fundamental thing